[Music]
[Applause]
all right let me bring in Andy Staples
covers college football for uh the
website on three Sports we've been
talking about Justin Fields take me back
to his last year at Ohio State was there
any real question about him being a
pocket passer at the next level
there were always those questions
because the the late Dwayne Haskins had
had some of the same issues coming out
of a similar offense and uh it was but
you saw Justin it was more about reading
the defense and about what he was asked
to do in that offense and I think that's
been
sort of a complaint about Ohio State
quarterbacks under Ryan day
um Joe burrow was there but then left to
go to LSU was running a different
offense at LSU
I I think that's that's going to be the
question until one of them kind of
breaks out and becomes a success in the
NFL is are they not asked to do the
things that they need to do and the
other just obvious thing with Ohio State
quarterbacks their receivers are so much
better than everyone else there's a
different kind of open at Ohio State
than somewhere else like I'll give you
an example Brock Purdy's receivers at
Iowa State weren't nearly as open as
Justin Fields receivers that so Brock
Purdy had to learn to fit it in there
Justin fields for the most part had
somebody wide open
but there's been that knock on Alabama
quarterbacks for years that hey anybody
can quarterback at Alabama you have all
those great receivers but we are getting
good quarterbacks coming out of there
well at least we had what happened with
Alabama with this year with these
quarterbacks right either they've missed
on some haven't developed the ones they
have or both because you know it you're
right it used to be oh Greg McElroy AJ
McCarron Jacob Coker it doesn't matter
you just put them in there they're so
much more talented than everybody else
all they have to do is not make mistakes
but as other teams got as talented as
Alabama and you had to deal with the
Clemsons and all that you did have to
have a more talented quarterback and
that's what Alabama did they changed the
way they recruited the quarterback
position they went more dual threat and
they had a historic think about this
that Jalen Hurts tuatanga by Loa Mac
Jones and Bryce young in succession
there's not gonna be a team in college
in
20 years that has that run that kind of
run
and so I think we got a little spoiled
with that and we also got a little
spoiled with them having really Dynamic
receivers I mean you think about when
they had Jalen waddle Devonte Smith
Henry rugs and Jerry Judy all at the
same time
that's just unfair it's what Ohio state
does everybody now but it's also not
possible to do year after year after
year after year
it was a year ago where Nick Saban kind
of complained about nil and he was
talking to his boosters he's basically
saying look we got a we gotta outspend
Texas a m a m hasn't cashed in on this
but
Alabama like what's going on here like
it's you know is it transfer portal nil
they're not taking advantage of either
one of those like other other schools no
I don't think it's that because when
they've needed to get somebody the
transfer portal like Jamison Williams a
couple years ago they did okay and and
so they've been able to spot recruit out
of the portal nil if they tell their
donors hey instead of rebuilding the
weight room we'd like you to donate to
nil they'll do it they'll do whatever
they need to do but I do think the
market in general has changed and you
know Andy Schwartz was an economist who
worked with the plaintiffs in O'Bannon
versus the NCAA and wrote this back back
then and said hey if all this stuff were
to come to be
you'll see the talent spread out more
and I think you're seeing that I mean
you in the class of 2024 Dan here's a
good example the number one defensive
lineman in the country is going to
Missouri he's from Missouri Missouri has
a state law that allows you to start
cashing in on nil deals September of
your senior year of high school so this
sort of thing is changing the Dynamics
the transfer portal is also changing it
because remember if you want to play in
the NFL
Matt Castle aside you got to play in
college so you you're not going to sit
the bench at Alabama or Ohio State or
Clemson or wherever for three years
waiting when you can go somewhere and
star right away and oh by the way
they'll give you an nil deal
but this so this isn't a case of Alabama
slipping as much as others are moving up
up the ladder where Alabama is different
I think one they can't select as well as
they could like it used to be they could
get anybody they wanted the moment Kirby
Smart went to Georgia that changed the
other thing that's happening with
Alabama is the bench of assistant
coaches is not that deep
remember Nick Saban was losing
assistance left and right but always
seemed to have somebody ready who was
either in that Nick Saban witness
relocation program that Mike Loxley
always joked about or had worked there
before gone somewhere else and was
coming back well this time they didn't
have that when like when Bill O'Brien
went to the Patriots they didn't have an
OC just ready to pull up which is
exactly what Georgia did this year when
they lost Todd monk into the Ravens so
they had to go do a national search they
talked to Brian grub at Washington they
talk to other people and they end up
hiring Tommy Reese for Notre Dame but
Tommy Reese had never worked with Nick
Saban before we don't know how well they
work together in the past Nick Saban has
usually picked somebody he has already
worked with and knows exactly what he's
going to get out of
uh
is there any Fallout of Clemson and or
Alabama don't make the playoffs this
year
there's a Fallout in terms of Clemson is
is probably going to have to to rethink
the way they do some things because
while Alabama has adjusted to the
changes in college sports Clemson has it
Dabo Sweeney has not wanted to use the
transfer portal I think the first time
he used it was last year to get Hunter
Johnson who was a quarterback at
Northwestern who had been a quarterback
at Clemson so he's basically just
bringing him back uh they have not
filled holes nearly as well because they
have not wanted to use the transfer
portal because Dabo doesn't believe in
that well he's probably going to have to
start believing in it yeah we're talking
to Andy Staples he covers college
football at uh on three Sports
Colorado these next two weekends
how important are these two games for
just this season well maybe for the the
entire program moving forward
well I think they're very important and
it but it's more about how you show up
it's not necessarily if you win if you
win either one of these games it is
awesome it they will be the biggest
story in sports if they can beat Oregon
this weekend but
if they can compete with Oregon this
weekend that should tell you they're
going to be a monster in the in the next
year or so because
when you revamp a roster the way they
did wholesale changes you can get skill
players out of the portal but it's very
hard to find big guys in the portal and
Oregon has really good players up front
both lines of scrimmage if they can hang
with what they have
they'll be able to get better big guys
this next year and all of a sudden
they'll be competitive with anybody now
I went into the the season before I saw
them play thinking they're this is a
game where they're just going to get
their doors blown off and it may happen
because they don't have Travis Hunter
but I've been really impressed with the
way they've played schematically Sean
Lewis the offensive coordinator was a
good head coach at Kent State he's done
a good job taking advantage of what they
do have and hiding what they don't
if they can keep doing that
I think they could be really good in the
coming years and then they've got USC at
home after that but I'm wondering once
again USC lacking defense they certainly
have offense but are they a final four
team with just an offensive minded team
I think they're better defensively this
year they went out and got some guys out
of the portal I remember I said there's
not a lot of good big guys available in
the portal but USC
tends to draw the the ones that are and
they got a guy named bear Alexander from
from Georgia to play defensive tackle
they got Anthony Lucas from Texas A M
who plays on the d-line as well body
types that USC just didn't have before
and most teams in the Pac-12 that aren't
Oregon or Utah don't have so I do think
they're going to be considerably better
defensively we'll see when they play
Colorado when they play Notre Dame but I
I suspect they're better than they were
last year speaking of Notre Dame they
got Ohio State
um how impactful is this game
it's huge I mean I was talking to Mike
Golic Jr who played center for the Irish
when they played for a national title in
2012. he said this feels bigger than any
of those games I was talking to some
people at Notre Dame they said this
feels like the biggest game since USC
came in in 05 on that campus and so this
is this is huge because they've got Sam
Hartman now quarterback which feels like
the piece they've been missing the thing
that that allows that offense to be more
explosive they just haven't had that in
the last few years so if you can beat in
Ohio State you can absolutely beat
anybody in the country and I do think
with this schedule
if they split Ohio State and USC and are
competitive in the one they lose they
could still make the 14 playoff at 11-1
have a great weekend Andy always great
to catch up with you thank you thanks
Dan Andy Staples covering college
football for on three Sports